goodbye Germany Dresden it's been fun
we're off to Rome that's wait we are
real in a Rome right now right
you have the itinerary got itinerary and
read itinerary are two different things
maybe Airport for that's cooler than
George no one here early why
do I go
I just got the honey milkshake for the
biggest straw ever it came out of the
little tiny machine she put that there
oh yeah
it's a hard phone
say
thanks young girl
Oh
the song
how do you
we thought we're gonna miss our plane
but it's actually being tossed around
see a picture of a bag
all 14 herbs that I love actually all
four words that I learn in German are
now useless to me
why do I get so
other things you do
over here over here yeah
it's been a 15-hour travel day which
probably should have taken five hours
this is not the hotel room that we were
supposed to be in we arrived at said
hotel that we were supposed to be at
other guys like oh I'm sorry there's
been a problem with your room and I'm
like okay cool it's midnight what do I
do I'm in a strange place I've never
been before
cool glad there's a problem but he
offers to ship us to another hotels and
now we're here we're starving we don't
know what's going on things are just
getting wild
I need vino food this food does this
mean room service how old do you think
long story short you're gonna be a
little claustrophobic though the guy
scared us because we were used to the
beds previously which were like twin
beds and he's like oh sorry we only have
a one bedroom or that we would be
sleeping on half of this me and Jenna
have been nice this is nice really pleat
it shoe sponge how much is a paint alone
14 euros working euro for Pantalone I've
got lots of Hippo loans how do we do
laundry
so Jenna's allergic to bananas and wood
we have a breakfast we had a banana and
strawberry smoothie so now she's not
feeling very well
that's an understatement here rather
like a tourist or now
holy moly we're here it's easy
how did how did this all happen we're
not sure don't ask questions this point
don't ask any questions just just live I
think I'm getting ripped off left and
right here
I just keep giving money and then they
don't give me any money back and I'm
like and this it you think I see and I
was like I don't know no wait you don't
know no no no worried we're in not in
Germany anymore which is unfortunate
because I learned like five words and I
can't even use them here so use one flaw
I'm Shiela gas station
everybody coin in but this is what I did
our first job on Days little trip tour
is the Trevi Fountain we just tossed in
a coin and I'm not really sure what
we're going to do tomorrow we're going
to be doing an entire big sort of
private tour of Rome that's going to be
really exciting
but today we're just kind of chilling
just kind of hanging out saying that we
can see try not to pass out from heat
exhaustion I'm a tourist
my shot here is tourists alert
I do have Google Maps if we get that
friend
we've been out for about 40 minutes and
we are now getting a stop for water in
gelato so that's what we're doing this
is where we are our view is incredible
right thank you
video video Ciao Bella homicide is the
best ice cream that you can try it's
gonna melt immediately so there's a guy
here who is from Pittsburgh and he's a
Steelers bar so we're gonna go
investigate the Steelers bar he better
be there because the bar opens at 4:00
so Giovanna Giovanni Giovanni Giovanni
Giovanni you're not there we're gonna be
barely upset there
right now we're heading to the Spanish
Steps and then we're going to steal a
car so I've been joking that I really
want to get Maddie something and
bringing back a present
you know just mommy thinking of him so
we walk past this place is called for
pets only and I got him the cutest
matching collar and leash set ever he's
gonna look great
also I'm not sure how you guys are
finding us but we keep running into you
guys on the street it's kind of
incredible
well as opposed to anything I think I
posted a get to you one thing about
using the trail mr. Dale
yeah the trail has been left retro
sleeping Tom's a lot of red rose a lot
of breadcrumbs that's all of you it
looks like it's closed for construction
or some things that we can't actually go
up it can you normally go up it I'm not
on a presen sure
I lost Jenna into the unlost in Roma
flossin Roma
Oh God
oh god I can't find them oh there you
are
I was lost in Roma
Oh silly yeah but like yes I have no
space for shopping is it usually closed
for construction
Oh
there's so much great shopping here but
here's the problem it's actually a good
problems that I don't buy anything I
don't have room for anything and the
fact that I just bought Maddie two
leashes and crawlers that's taking up
room very precious room so I want to
know I've got so many questions the u.s.
just spills will your water bottles
except up here but like we're just water
come from like it tastes better than the
water that was in my bottle before this
so where does that water come from and
am I gonna be okay I guess we're gonna
find out in about an hour after I drink
this bottle of water is it go ahead I
want to pour it on the body where does
it come from
tastes good though fresh gentle where we
going for the far baby off to the Stila
bar was it called okay
she doesn't know I don't know I almost
got hit by a car guys what the heck is a
Twizy how do I get one
what does it run on as a gas power is an
electric it felt like it looks like it
will exit it now that's a lot of 20s
smart car
the shot got the shot Hey
they been delighted I'm famous so you
better better is it a year is this
really going I'm not bars Wow this is it
yeah we finally made it okay how do we
say it right LaBolt about the cella is
that right yeah okay see you're from
Pittsburgh correct
come on you're not okay from row okay
but then why why is it a Pittsburgh bar
because I'm a big Pittsburgh this is
great so now that we have the story
right you're not from surgery your crumb
realm Pittsburgh fan so you guys have to
come here we found it all right let's
get can we have a beverage
where he does it oh my goodness this is
so great Pittsburgh sill anyone this is
incredible I feel like I'm at home
it's always so fun going to other places
and things are sort of out of place like
this place is filled with Steelers gear
and Pittsburgh things and it's so
incredible so if you guys are from
Pittsburgh you're gonna absolutely lose
your mind you ever happen to find
yourself a row
here's a little piece of Pittsburgh
get your face out of it this is so much
fun okay let's give it up there
we're gonna be having an Aperol spritz
which the first time I had one of these
in New York
Franchesca made me try it and it was
incredible
she has me on Facebook we want to see
how many friends we got in common
hey I was walking away and Jenna goes I
think somebody's screaming iJustine and
it was this table yeah okay we'll enjoy
your salad I love your you yes watching
you thank you watching you I wanted
every it's okay like you know like once
a month okay yeah well I wanna start
right you too alright we've arrived to a
restaurant we're eating it all frayed
face of a rigid cup of the shut-eye I'll
prepared of no way I haven't had that
Aegina operator and so long but guess
what I'm getting today guess what I'm
getting today guys I'm getting better
gee this is so exciting
this is nice nice taste Cheers
this is the birthplace of fettuccine
alfredo so
my god I want to put it all over my body
we just had a great meal at the original
place who they first made Alfredo
sorry different chat really what Charlie
figure out how to do laundry you think
it'd be easier but they kind of like
trick you by marking things down I'm not
sure I'm just excited to have clean
clothes either way it's time for bed and
tomorrow we're doing a really fun tour
around Rome so stay tuned for that video
I'm gonna edit this video and I'll see
you guys tomorrow or the next day
yes I'm not getting out of anywhere
because I guys know I forgot to show you
what I got Madi but I'm too tired and I
wrapped it all up nice
I am unable to control how happy I am
right now